welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we've been watching The
Watchmen to break down everything that
you need to know about the show and the
characters in it throughout this video
we're going to be discussing the
mysterious lady true and going over the
best fan theories about her origin story
and what an overall plan could be there
will be heavy spoilers here so for you
aren't fully caught up on the show and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for daily breakdowns just like this and
without the way thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into who a lady
true is lady true played by hong jiao is
a world-famous trillionaire that owns a
vast majority of businesses and research
departments that specialize in cloning
pharmaceuticals and temporal devices
true is a futurist who seems to have an
unlimited amount of resources at her
disposal and the means to get whatever
she wants this is exemplified in her
introduction in Watchmen episode 4 in
which the character wishes to trade a
newborn baby with a couple who are
unable to have children and exchange for
their land using DNA samples true has
managed to create the child from their
genetics and it's clear that she has the
means and abilities to play God with
whoever she chooses true also owns all
of Awesome and uses corporations and
subsidiaries after purchasing them in
2012 she seems to be obsessed with the
character erecting a mysterious location
known as the millenium clock on the
outskirts of Tulsa and breaking the
ground by quoting Shelley's poem
Ozymandias most notably the line look
upon my works ye mighty and despair the
character also keeps a golden statue of
Ozymandias company and her Bavarian
bears a striking similarity to the one
that might had at his palace in Karnak
she clearly knows that the character is
still alive because of her accidental
use of the present tense when discussing
him I'll get into the more major
connection between the two later but I
thought I'd just drop that in before we
talk we're vias later on lady true hells
from vietnam
outside of this berry little is actually
known about her character
the name lady true actually comes from a
third century Vietnam warrior lady true
managed to resist the Chinese occupation
of Vietnam and she is pretty much known
as the Joan of Arc of the country now
Vietnam is a massively important part of
watchman law and actually differs
massively from the real world country
that we know today in watchman history
America actually won the Vietnam War
because of dr. Manhattan and since then
it has become part of the United States
this is why the American flag in the
show differs slightly to the one that we
know as it contains Vietnam and several
of the territories this explains why
true is able to accumulate such a vast
fortune and easily operate within the US
as they are technically all part of the
same entity it's clear that true had a
troubled childhood and this has in some
strange way been passed on to her
daughter who is too haunted by her
memories initially a lot of people guess
that this was because trues daughter was
a clone and was somehow carrying her
memories and this may be true however I
have another possibility
we know that true upon purchasing bytes
companies brought his perfume range
nostalgia over and then repurposed the
name into a range of pills that are
literally memories when researching this
product through HBO's supplementary
material on the show there is a warning
that if one takes the pills whilst
pregnant that they had the potential to
fuse with the fetus and this may cause
the child to retain the memories of
their parents to me this explains why
trues daughter remembers the vietnam war
it's also reasons like this that the
pills were outlawed just just don't say
they're Angelo's pills that's that's a
little joke for people who watch my last
watchman video though I'm sorry YouTube
I'm an idiot anyway the Vietnam memories
themselves could also paint out the
truth about who true truly is in the
Watchmen graphic novel we learned that
during the Vietnam War the comedian
ended up getting one of the locals
pregnant and in a fit of rage he
murdered her it could be possible that
true is actually the daughter of this
woman and though the mother died there
is potential that the baby was saved
dr. Manhattan was present during all of
this and though it seemed like he did
not act on the murder he may have
intervened to save the child now this is
a big point
and I can see a lot of people
disagreeing with it however during the
outburst the comedian did say that the
doc could have saved her at any moment
but he chose not to
which cemented that he was truly
detached from humanity
we know from Ozymandias that this is not
the case and he states that John shows
his emotions through micro expressions
and whilst the majority of people are
too unaware to pick them up to him the
doc might as well have been sobbing this
makes me believe that during this murder
dr. Manhattan still had an attachment to
humanity and he saved the child which
later grew up to be lady true dr.
Manhattan has the ability to see every
moment in his life simultaneously and if
his future version was interacting with
true then that would mean that this past
version would have to save her during
this time it's all complicated how the
time stuff works with Doc but there is a
causality in which everything has to
happen the way that it happens doc sums
it up when he says we are all puppets I
can just see the strings there for his
past has to line up with his future and
though he doesn't necessarily have free
will he is complicit and carrying our
actions that lead to the future anyway
whatever the case dr. Manhattan during
the war would have been aware of trues
importance in the future so he would
have known about her existence during
the conflict whether she is the
comedian's daughter and therefore
Laurie's half-sister or not remains to
be seen but there is a lot of potential
that the two interacted early on and he
may have been instrumental in how she
was able to gain such wealth we know
that dr. Manhattan is able to create
duplicates of himself and this could
have been the key to true discovering
how to create clones she already runs a
successful business at forever pets that
carries this out and doc could have
given her the wisdom of how to create
replicas of cells there is another
aspect of the show that deals massively
in clones and this is a huge aesthetic
of Ozymandias prison whenever we see the
character he is typically joined by
clones of both male and female servants
who attend to his every whim without
question except except for the game
warden of course these clones have
likely been created by true in order to
serve and keep him on the grounds of his
prison personally I believe they're
after the election of Robert Redford as
he realized that the world was not going
to end up becoming the utopia that he
had once envisioned and thus
became depressed and fed up with
humanity sharing a similarity with dr.
Manhattan he decided to ostracize
himself and he sell this company to true
divulging all of his secrets in the
process hoes he just wished to be away
from all and for me this is cemented by
the line in which he says that he
originally arrived at the castle and its
grounds are believing it to be a
paradise but he soon realized that it
was a prison it's also possible that doc
and true help cause he moved to the
prison and true may have created the
environment with the same skills that
she used to birth over barium and then
doc created the castle we did see an
episode one that he was building a
castle
on Mars and this bore a striking
resemblance to Aziz so perhaps this was
a prototype of the one that would
eventually come to be on the moon that
Ozzie now inhabits dr. Manhattan can
teleport anywhere at once along with
others so this would make it possible
for him to take Ozzie anywhere in the
galaxy at a moment's notice
Ozzie is probably on the Jupiter moon
Europa and we did see him arranging the
corpses of clones to spell out save me D
which could be a call-out to dr.
Manhattan because the character wishes
to return to Earth as he is pulled back
into his prison and we are then told
that he will be put on trial and
potentially this could have him being
found guilty and therefore he will be
sent back to earth for breaking the
terms of his agreement it is possible at
the meteor that we see crashing down to
earth on the farm in the fourth episode
is Ozzy coming back and this would be by
true wish to purchase the property the
gold statue that we see of the character
could literally be the character encased
in gold which yet not a nice way to go
how true managed to predict this crash
well it could be because the clock that
she is building tells time when the
clock is discussed it is specified as
something that can quote-unquote tell
time and this may mean that through it
the user is able to see their own future
and past similar to dr. Manhattan we
know that true has a fascination with
the past to turnest al J and this could
be an extension of that which explains
how she is able to know to be at the
forum for the arrival of the meteorite
it's also a theory that the JED Crawford
that we see hanging in episode one is
actually just a clone of the character
and he's still out there somewhere
working with the seven cavalry but yeah
that's that's for another video
oh we're although true is a fascinating
character
and how this video has opened your mind
up to what could be going on with her
and where the show might be heading
I just wanted to redeem myself for the
Angela pill statement so yeah thanks
thanks for sticking with me now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on lady true and what you think is going
to happen in the show going forward
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of the series so far
which would be linked at the end we go
through the show episode by episode
discussing all of the things that you
missed so it's definitely worth staying
locked to the channel if you want to
know more if you want to come chat to me
after the video that makes you follow me
on twitter at definition YT or head over
to my discord server which we linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on Lady true in the
comments section below but when it's
gonna be chosen on the 15th of December
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]